while President Trump had a bizarre
exchange with Jim Acosta of CNN today
Acosta suggested the president had a
duty of some kind to take a question
about judge Cavanaugh from a female
reporter just as soon as Jim Acosta got
to ask a question if you don't mind
after I'm finished if we juror Halle or
Vivian or one of our female colleagues
could go after me that would be great
mr. president just to follow up on these
allegations against what does he mean by
that
explain what what is what is that I
think we great a foot if a female what
does it mean we're know what does it
mean be great if a female reporter were
to ask you a question about the this
issue so if you don't mind I wouldn't
mind that at all I wouldn't mind it at a
heart well let me make any difference to
me all right go ahead Jim Acosta big
warrior for women so obviously gets to
go first author and columnist mark Stein
joins us tonight so what let's let's
just be literal for a minute no what
does that mean exactly I'm not sure I am
in fear in press conferences though if
Jim Acosta is in the room I am in favor
of women and children all the lifeboats
are gone before Jim Acosta stirred gun
this is this is actually far more
condescending and sexist than all the
old dead white Republican men on the
Senate Judiciary Committee you know
Chuck Grassley and Orrin Hatch in in
their worst nightmares couldn't be more
sexist than condescending than their
women reporters generally a tough they
don't need gentlemen Jim Acosta to hold
the door for them to let them through so
they can get a question in Rosalind
Russell in his girl Friday 1939 18 years
ago Rose Russell played at eff
no-nonsense reporter Sheena punch Jim
Acosta's lights out for the anyone
making any specific claims against
anybody but have you noticed as you've
lived in this country for a long time
that the people who make the loudest
noises about what feminists they are
tend to have a more spotty record with
women in their own lives yes I think
that's absolutely true and I think
that's actually
what's underpinning some of this I think
there's an element of projection in the
whole Democrat media savagery on this
cavern is you they've had a rough year
you know they've they've lost the
senator they've lost Canas in the house
on the Democrat side on the media
they've lost some of the most fated
figures whether it's Charlie Rose
whether yes Matt Lauer whether it's
Harvey Weinstein all these people that
Kirsten Gillibrand has been photographed
well let me ask you about Kirsten
Gillibrand so she has not through the
course of this Cavanaugh story hasn't
simply ignored due process or the
presumption of innocence
she's bragged about ignoring those
things watch this to those who are here
say over and over this isn't fair to
judge Kavanagh he's entitled to due
process what about the presumption of
innocence until proven guilty he's not
entitled to those because we're not
actually seeking to convict him so we
have another setback we should not
complete something I can handle it but
she basically says if you support due
process and presumption of innocence
you're part of the problem please just
shut up yeah
if this kind of feels like the beginning
of something new and ominous no it's a
it's absolutely awful this this is the
vikon sang cues Lord Chancellor in
England and actually did the thing that
eventually became the UN declaration of
human rights the presumption of
innocence isn't just a criminal court
value it's actually a human right it's a
civilizational value and and it's what
Vai count sank he called the golden
thread in English law and what these
people like Kirsten Gillibrand who is a
lawyer it's actually doing is taking the
scissors and cutting up the golden
thread now she says hold it's not a
Criminal Court
no it's beyond that it's the Senate in
its advise and consent
actually it's the it's the u.s.
equivalent of the Lord Chancellor the
Lord Chancellor in England appoints
judges the Senate does it here and so
what that does when the state actually
says there's no presumption of innocence
100 Americans out of 300 million get to
be US senators
and if they don't believe in the
presumption of innocence that's
something that every American should be
concerned about when when the most
powerful figures in the line like
Kirsten Gillibrand are willing to trash
you mentioned Maher judge for the next
30 years when anybody Google's his name
all they're gonna see is that he
apparently led all these gang rape
parties all across the lesson is
unbelievable so many people are being
destroyed now and everyone's terrified
mark Stein thank you very much
thanks a lot